Cheetah's populations are declining because
they're fast, but they're not the smartest
cat in the box.
Ever since I was a kid, I loved the cheetah.
It's definitely one of my favorite animals
on our planet.
Cheetahs are speedy, as you probably know.
They can hit top speeds of 70 to 75 mph (112
to 120 kph).
They live mainly in Africa, though they can
also be found in the Middle East.
Cheetahs are notoriously difficult to breed
in captivity, and don't rebound from population
destruction very easily.
In 1900, the cheetah population was around
100,000.
Today it's more like 10,000 and YES we are
to blame, climate changes, habitat destruction,
the whole 9 yards.
We're seriously screwing up this planet but
hey that's not the important thing here, is
it?
By some measures, cheetahs are doing this
to themselves.
Researchers from three continents worked together
to learn more about how the cheetah is contributing
to its own demise -- their paper in the journal
Science is titled, "Cheetahs never prosper."
// LOL good one, guys.
It all comes back to their speed.
Cheetah evolution has afforded them super
speed, but not much else.
They don't have the heaviest claws or the
strongest defenses.
Their defensive play is the same as their
offense, they run.
Once they've made a kill, they don't really
defend it.
C'mon cheetahs!
What are you doing, man!
There's no playground mother to tell, you
just gotta get in there!
Hyenas and lions take advantage of their packs
and strength to steal kills from cheetahs,
driving the zippy kitty away; forcing it to
expend even more energy looking for a new
meal.
According to the researchers, the energy a
cheetah uses to make a single kill is QUOTE
"relatively small, even taking into account
their bursts of speed.
[Instead],the biggest driver of energy expenditure
for cheetahs turned out to be the distance
they had to walk in order to find their prey."
Because their kills weren't being defended,
cheetahs aren't able to regain the energy
they'd lost looking for a new catch.
You might be thinking, DAMN THOSE LIONS AND
HYENAS.
Stealing the cute little cheetah's food….
But that's not the REAL problem.
The problem is these cats have to trek across
farmland, and around fences or walls.
Yeah.
It's humans again.
Cheetahs are walking themselves to death in
order to find safe hunting grounds.
Remember how I said it wasn't about us this
time?
Yeah, I lied.
We're the problem again.
Added to that, the cheetah is pretty easy
to tame and has now become a luxury pet in
the Middle East.
It is possible to tame cheetahs and have them
walk on a leash and play safely with humans,
and ancient African royalty would take them
as hunting pets.
Because of this, poachers steal the cheetah
cubs, further increasing their level of population
decline.
We're awful.
How does this make you feel?
Want to do something about it?
Last year for Discovery's company-wide volunteer
day, I went to the National Zoo to help clean
the cheetah pens, just for a chance to get
close to one.
They're HUGE, like, Great Dane sized, and
if you get a chance to volunteer with your
local zoos you should.
It's rewarding, and can really help understand
the impact humans are having on these beautiful
animals.